- So before we go.
So I hear that you have
an apology to make?
- I do. Okay.
So, the way I got booked on the show,
I was at the Critics' Choice Awards
and two of your producers
were at the table
and Dave, who is an amazing
person, he was, yes,
over there in the blue, he cute.
He was booking me.
He was like, you should
be on Kelly Clarkson.
Because I told him you tip
well, and as he was booking me,
as he's booking me, my
cousin was over here,
she was like, girl, Venus
Williams is over there,
let's go take a picture.
I run away from him
to go take a picture with Venus Williams.
And when I came back, I was like
did y'all see me talking to Venus?
And my producer was like Joyelle,
he was trying to book you
for "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
and then you spilled red
wine all over his tux
after I ran away from the table.
So I apologize, Dave. Profusely. Yes.
- Wait. But wait!
How's... oh Dave, that's a rough one.
How is your shirt and tux now? Is it...?
- I mean, it was a little
messy, but the shirt survived.
We're good, we made it work.
- I'm just gonna say I love you
and I'll buy you another shirt.
I think Venus was worth it. The run.
- [Joyelle] Absolutely.
- Yeah, yeah.
Worth the run, yes.
- Absolutely she was.
Because it was a black
girl magic selfie so,
there was a lot going on in that building.
It was Halle Berry, it was
Will Smith and Jada Pinkett,
I just, I was googoo y'all,
I be starstruck so.
Look at that! Yes!
Yes!
Amber Ruffin, Jodi
Turner-Smith, Venus Williams,
Danielle Brooks, and my cousin Joy,
who was the bold one that
said let's go over there
because she's an Aries from
Atlanta so she's very bold.
- [Kelly] Oh, Aries are bold.
- Very bold.